I don't I think we are off on a mission
today there is a Luigi's Mansion
installment here the Nintendo is putting
on they invited Jenna and I and we were
out of previous shoot so we have Maddie
and I don't think it's like that for me
but you had to bring it because we had
him with us great man coming to downtown
is like an event downtown this is
[Music]
look how spooky
this is something that I never thought
would ever happen not only are we in
Luigi's Mansion but Maddie is in the
mansion money should go get a picture
you have reservation
okay right this way I do apologize we're
having a bit of a ghost infestation yes
he would potty on the plans this is so
cool
oh my god you can get through the bars
you know yeah he's made of goo jealous
I know super spooky
[Music]
we're inside now Maddie made it inside
there's all kinds of little game
stations set up there's a library over
here for the tents which light where you
can place a multiplayer they brought
snacks Jenna yeah I think we'll brunch
right let's go check out this next verse
spooky popcorn there's a spooky mac and
cheese I'm going to campus with Jenna
[Music]
well I think I'm now officially a ghost
hunter this is so cool I like that
leaves in my shoes now Maddie scared
it's okay many and just I'm taking care
of business the ghosts
[Music]
this looks great
mommy Juun mac and cheese a little
noodle
that was my fork but Maddy is living his
best life
[Music]
alright Maddy it's time to go but they
were heading out we have so much fun
here at Luigi's Mansion pop-up this is
incredible I cannot wait to play the
game
it'll be out very very soon October 31st
they say yes Halloween happy Halloween
to me
[Music]